so would you say weak men is the roots
of absolutely the weak men are the
biggest problem in the world we've men
are in charge now it used to be that the
the masking leader the fighter or
somebody like that the the warrior would
lead charged but ever since technology
social media you could be able to poke
girls I would say this whole time Mark
Zuckerberg and created Facebook he was a
nerd and he started like he based
Facebook off of hot or not and so now
this nerd was able to go and
uh own the sexual Marketplace he was
able to judge all these women who would
have he would have never had access to
before and that was a shift in 2007 now
the nerd is in charge rather than the
warrior